[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis einst schönen guten abend
wünsche ich der sport mit norbert
lehmann und den dfb-pokal hund angel
bonndorfer die großen themen heute unter
anderem die lage in der ukraine
schwere kämpfe in der ost ukraine mario
pohl angeblich unter russischer
kontrolle der angriff auf das stahlwerk
dort ist offenbar gestoppt
waffenhilfe als ringtausch gemeinsam mit
partnerländern will die bundesregierung
waffensysteme liefern die möglichst
schnell eingesetzt werden können
und fernsehduell vor der stichwahl in
frankreich präsident immer nur im markt
und die extrem rechte marine le pen
werben um die stimmen der
unentschlossenen
die welt blickt weiter auf die ukraine
us-präsident beiden kündigt weitere
militärhilfe an und auch deutschland
will sich nun über umwege an der
lieferung schwerer waffen beteiligen
währenddessen geht die russische
großoffensive weiter entlang der front
in der ost ukraine toben heftige kämpfe
die hafenstadt mario pohl hat nach
russland nach eigenen angaben nun unter
kontrolle
mit ausnahme des stahlwerks of style
statt es zu stürmen soll es nun
abgeregelt werden pablo sie lala
die einst stolze hafenstadt mariupol
nach acht wochen belagerung nur noch ein
trümmerfeld die menschen wollen nur noch
eins möglichst schnell weg
und mittendrin diese szene des triumphs
ein russischer panzer dreht im zentrum
von mario pohl eine pirouette zuvor
hatte moskau gemeldet die stadt sei
komplett unter russischer kontrolle auch
wenn der bürgermeister das dementiert
die letzte große von ukrainischen
truppen gehalten bastion das oft als
stahlberg neben den soldaten sollen auch
rund 1000 zivilisten dort zuflucht
gesucht haben das fabrikgelände ist ein
weiträumiger komplex mit zahlreichen
tunneln seinen plan das werk zu stürmen
hat russland vorerst aufgegeben nun
verfolgt präsident putin eine andere
taktik
die geplante erstürmung des
industriegebiets halte ich für sinnlos
ich befehle es abzubrechen es ist nicht
nötig in diese katakomben zu klettern
und durch diese industrieanlagen zu
kriechen sperren sie dieses
industriegebiet ab damit nicht einmal
eine fliege dadurch kommt
mit der einnahme marke joop als hätte
die ukraine den letzten hafen am
asowschen meer verloren russland würde
dann auch den küstenabschnitt zwischen
der krim und der donbass region
kontrollieren für die ukraine ein
schwerer schlag
explosionen werden auch aus anderen
orten gemeldet wie aus charkiw der
zweitgrößten stadt des landes seit fast
zwei monaten harren viele menschen hier
in u bahnhöfen aus ukrainische truppen
verteidigen die stadt mit raketen davon
präsidentiellen ski gibt sich
kämpferisch
wir wollen durch eine großoffensive
wenigstens einen teil sieg erringen
damit sie etwas haben um ihre
propagandisten zu füttern in der region
kiew gibt es in das neue hinweise auf
mögliche kriegsverbrechen im vorort roth
janker sollen neue massengräber entdeckt
worden seien darin neun leichen von
zivilisten einige mit folterspuren die
bilder erinnern an die gräueltaten im
nahegelegenen butscher
und in der ukraine ist für uns doch
niklas meister dominik ist das so ist
mario pohl komplett unter russischer
kontrolle
der präsident selensky hält diese stadt
noch nicht komplett unter russische
kontrolle er ist der meinung dass man
die stadt auch noch zurückerobern könnte
auch der bürgermeister von mario pohl
sagte dass man in der stadt auch noch
stellungen habe an denen gekämpft werde
das heißt diese informationen sind für
uns schwer zu beurteilen weil wir selbst
ja auch keine journalisten und kollegen
dort haben die uns informationen geben
können heute jedenfalls sind drei busse
aus mario pohl rausgekommen heute
nachmittag
da waren etwa 80 leute drin frauen und
kinder aber das ist natürlich eine ganz
verschwindend geringe zahl der
bürgermeister sprach von 100.000
menschen die weiter in dieser stadt
ausharren ohne strom ohne wasser ohne
lebensmittel und es ist quasi jeden tag
ein kampf darum diese busse
reinzubringen menschen raus zu bringen
und auch diese situation in dem
stahlwerk ist katastrophal die
ukrainische seite bietet ja das
verletzte und auch die zivilisten
rausgebracht werden können aber moskauer
ist er bisher hart dank für diese
einschätzung domnick löschmeister und
jetzt immer noch eine reportage von
ihnen damit lässt meister hat nämlich
eine ukrainische einheit dabei begleitet
wie sie nahe der hauptstadt kiew wien
und nicht detonierte geschosse
entschärft ein lebensgefährlicher
granaten blindgänger minen vielerorts in
den zerstörten vororten von kiew findet
man die hinterlassenschaften der
russischen armee es ist eine gefahr für
die menschen die dort leben und auch
zurück kommen stanislaw zeigt uns den
sprengkörper den er vor seinem haus
entdeckt hat passiert ist ihm nichts
erkennt es auch anders
ich habe freunde verloren einige wurden
von den bienen splittern betrügt
die russischen truppen haben nach
ukrainischen angaben auch sprengfallen
zurückgelassen das vorgehen habe system
berichtet dieser ukrainische soldat
sie legen ringe schmuck und halsketten
als sprengfallen aus sie graben ein loch
darunter und leben dort sprengstoff
hinein dasselbe gilt für kinderspielzeug
und die leichen ihrer eigenen soldaten
der kampfmittelräumdienst der käfer
polizei sammelt jeden tag minen und
sprengkörper 1 die bevölkerung kann sich
melden dann wird die munition abgeholt
und dieser sandgrube außerhalb von kiew
sammeln sie das explosive material um es
später kontrolliert zu sprengen
aus meiner erfahrung kann ich sagen dass
ein jahr krieg zehn jahre minenräumen
bedeutet also brauchen wir nach diesem
kriegsmonaten kiew mindestens ein jahr
für die räumung terminen
es ist ein gefährlicher job erst am
wochenende starben drei junge
bombenentschärfer an diesem nachmittag
geht alles gut mit der sprengung
weitere militärische hilfe kann die
ukraine aus den usa erwarten washington
will waffen und munition im wert von bis
zu 800 millionen dollar liefern us
präsident biden kündigte an dass das
neue paket unter anderem dutzende
haubitzen und aufklärungsdrohnen
enthalten werde erst vergangene woche
hatte beiden der ukraine rüstungsgüter
im gleichen umfang zugesagt
was die lieferung schwerer waffen angeht
plant die bundesregierung zum beispiel
folgendes osteuropäische länder wie
slowenien liefern der ukraine panzer aus
sowjetzeiten unterhalten dann von
deutschland hilfe bei der beschaffung
von ersatz christian vom vorsitzende des
europa-ausschusses im bundestag anton
hofreiter von den grünen für einen
langen krieg würde das alte so wird
material nicht ausreichen so hofreiter
über den geplanten ringtausch richter
klaus brodbeck
darum geht s t 72 panzer aus sowjet
zeiten wie diese hier sollen von
osteuropäischen partnern etwas nur
wenigen an die ukraine geliefert und von
ihr sofort eingesetzt werden dabei
entstehende lücken könnten dann nach und
nach mit panzern aus deutschland wieder
aufgefüllt werden die sachen tausch
würde gewährleisten dass schnell
geliefert werden kann und vor allem ohne
erforderliche ausbildungszeiten das ist
das was die ukraine jetzt braucht wir
stehen zur verfügung diese staaten zu
unterstützen die aus ihren beständen
jetzt leisten damit ihre
landesverteidigung da nicht geschwächt
wird möglicher ersatz mader aus
deutschland geliefert allerdings nicht
direkt von der bundeswehr sondern aus
beständen der industrie die es doch
aufgearbeitet werden müssen die weitere
verschärfung des kurses gegen russland
zeichnete sich heute auch beim besuch
der aussenministerin in estland ab
baerbock kündigt dort eine neue
sanktionspaket an die arbeiten an diesen
nächsten paket in brüssel die laufen
bereits wir werden den druck auf die
russische kriegsmaschinerie weiter
erhöhen und gleichzeitig alles dafür tun
um die ukraine mit waffen und ausrüstung
weiter zu unterstützen
auch radpanzer fuchs könnte deutschland
auf diese weise aus industrie beständen
abgeben außerdem soll die ukraine solche
panzerhaubitzen 2000 mit großer
reichweite erhalten geliefert von den
niederlanden die ausbildung ukrainische
soldaten an den geschützen könnte in
deutschland erfolgen das hatte die
regierung lange abgelehnt
und um waffen für die ukraine geht es
auch bei heute live um 19 30 im
interview da auch die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses im bundestag
marie agnes strack zimmermann von der
fdp und sie können das ganze in der zdf-
heute- app und auf unseren social media
kanälen verfolgen
seit kriegsbeginn sind mehr als fünf
millionen menschen aus der ukraine
geflüchtet fast drei millionen allein
ins nachbarland polen an der grenze gibt
es inzwischen allerdings ein
regelrechtes kommen und gehen allein
gestern kamen rund 22.000 menschen nach
polen aber ebenso viele ging zurück in
die ukraine aus ganz verschiedenen
gründen wie natalie steger an den
grenzübergängen chemische um medica
erfahren hat
ukraine renault lena am polnischen
grenzbahnhof in chemische doch sie ist
hier nicht gerade angekommen sie will
zurück in ihr land
ich gehe zurück weil da die jungs sind
die hilfe brauchen für die ich kochen
werde ich glaube ich bin immer noch
fähig zu helfen und deswegen fahre ich
zurück nach
kuba am grenzübergang im polnischen mit
dicker immer noch einkommen aber auch
eingehe viele wollen gerade jetzt zurück
in die ukraine weil am wochenende das
orthodoxe osterfest land steht meine
mama meine mama hat geburtstag und
ostern ist bald deswegen habe ich mich
entschieden zurück zu gehen das hat
nichts mit rationalem denken zu tun aber
krieg ist eine zeit in der das herz
spricht
doch mit der massiven russischen
offensive im osten dürften auch wieder
mehr flüchtlinge nach polen kommen so
wie sie
ich habe keine worte ich will nach hause
zurück nach hause
geflohen vor dem krieg und doch der
drang schnell wieder zurück zu gehen
auch im ukrainischen haus im polnischen
chemische bemerkten sie seit tagen eine
rückkehr welle
wir können niemanden zwingen aber
manchmal versuchen wir zu überzeugen
besonders mütter mit kleinen kindern
noch eine weile zu warten es ist noch
etwas zu früh aufschriften die letzten
meter bis zur passkontrolle und
dann fährt der zug mit den flüchtlingen
zurück in die ukraine ins kriegsgebiet
doch es ist ihr zuhause
soweit zum krieg in der ukraine nach
frankreich drei tage noch dann
entscheiden die wahlberechtigten dort
wer für die nächsten fünf jahre ihr
präsident oder ihre präsidentin wird
gestern beim einzigen fernsehduell
kämpften die rechtsextreme le pen und
amtsinhaber makro noch mal um jede
stimme knapp 16 millionen menschen sahen
sich die debatte an und es ging um sehr
viel denn etwa zehn prozent der
wahlberechtigten sagen aktuell wir
wollen wählen gehen wissen aber noch
nicht wen christian haas über den
wahlkampf endspurt
am tag danach sind beide konkurrenten
wieder im kontakt mit potenziellen
wählern immer nur makro ins antoni wo
viele einwanderer leben marine le pen
bei lastwagenfahrern in einem kleinen
ort im norden zwei kandidaten zwei
unterschiedliche visionen für frankreich
etwa beim thema europa
sie wollen immer noch raus aber sie
sagen es nicht ich glaube an europa und
an das deutsch französische paar unsere
souveränität ist national und europäisch
ich möchte in der eu bleiben aber ich
möchte sie tief greifend verändern um
eine europäische allianz der nationen zu
erreichen
marie le pen wirkt konzentriert emanuel
makro angriffslustig vor allem als es um
das verhältnis zu russland geht und die
bande sie sind abhängig von der
russischen macht und von putin sie haben
2015 einen kredit bei einer russischen
bank aufgenommen die der regierung in
moskau nahe steht
ich bin eine absolut freie frau ich bin
patriot in und verteidige das habe ich
immer gezeigt frankreich und die
franzosen
fast drei stunden streitgespräch
meinungen
es war ein starker moment der demokratie
diese debatte es war zwischen pest und
cholera ich werde dieses wochenende
nicht werden
eine blitzumfrage hat ergeben makro war
für die meisten befragten überzeugender
und dann gab es heute noch das in einer
zeitung die regierungschefs von
deutschland spanien und portugal rufen
zur wiederwahl macros auf ohne ihn
direkt beim namen zu nennen europa
brauche ein frankreich das für die
gemeinsamen werte einstehen sicher ist
es wird ein enges rennen entscheidung am
sonntag
ein bußgeld muss grossbritanniens
premier johnson wegen verstoßes gegen
korona regeln bereits bezahlen nun haben
die partys in seinem amtssitz auf ein
parlamentarisches nachspiel
das britische unterhaus leitete eine
untersuchung ein ob johnson die
abgeordneten belogen hat johnson
beteuerte erneut haben nichts zu
verbergen
wie geht es weiter bei den linken
gestern der überraschende rücktritt der
co vorsitzenden susanne hennig will so
jetzt der einstimmige beschluss des
vorstandes janine wissler soll die
partei zunächst alleine führen neue
weichen könnten auf dem parteitag im
juni gestellt werden rückendeckung
erhielt rösler von ihrem hessischen
landesverband in der affäre um sexismus
vorwürfe habe sie sich nichts zuschulden
kommen lassen
schauen wir auf corona nach den
auffällig niedrigen zahlen über ostern
werden jetzt wieder deutlich mehr
neuinfektionen gemeldet offenbar wurde
weniger getestet und nun haft gemeldet
der blick auf die letzten tage zeigt wie
die zahlen über die feiertage deutlich
sinken und dann wieder nach oben
anziehen fachleute gehen allerdings von
noch höheren zahlen aus wo also stehen
wir tatsächlich in dieser pandemie
stephanie heine und markus gross
die teststationen sind weniger geworden
die schlangen davor vergangenheit die
zahl der schnell und pcr tests geht
zurück wir haben nicht festgestellt dass
sich leute jetzt zu hause mehr testen
und weniger in den test station sollen
wir glauben dass die leute einfach
generell nicht mehr testen weil es jetzt
nicht mehr verpflichtend ist das hat zur
folge dass es laut experten doppelt so
viele corona infektionen geben könnte
wie derzeit mit pcr tests bestätigt
werden in den gesundheitsämtern blicken
sie deshalb auch auf andere zahlen es
ist nur so dass beim rk ii also beim
robert-koch-institut die schnelltest
nicht in die statistik einfließen sehr
wohl aber in den kommunen vorliegen ein
beispiel wir haben in neukölln offiziell
eine incident von
224 und unserer statistik in der wir
auch die positiven schnelltest
aufgenommen haben haben aktuell einen
intelligenz von 415 solche zahlen helfen
auch kliniken sich vorzubereiten
aktuell gehen dort die zahlen positiv
getesteter zurück auf den
intensivstationen seit letzter woche um
5,5 prozent auf den normalen stationen
um 6,9 prozent das ist das eine der
zweite effekt für die krankenhäuser sind
aber die hohen ausfall zahlen beim
personal die menschen stecken sich im
privaten umfeld an oder sie müssen auf
ihre infizierten angehörigen vielfach
kinder achten und fallen deshalb aus
auch wenn die zahlen wohl tendenziell
rückläufig sind nach wie vor werden die
tests für alle empfohlen die auf
besonders empfindliche menschen treffen
um diese funktion zu schützen
das zdf trauert um hans janke der
langjährige fernsehspielchef verstarb im
alter von 77 jahren in wiesbaden als
einen garanten für höchste filmqualität
im zdf würde ich die ihn intendant
norbert himmler janka fand das label
fernsehfilm der woche sein name bleibt
auch verbunden mit erfolgreichen
freitags krimis wie derrick der alte und
ein fall für zwei
und jetzt wird es
kollegin elisabeth ii zweite feiert
ihren 96 geburtstag die queen zeigte
sich allerdings nur per foto eingerahmt
von zwei schneeweißen ponys es heißt sie
begehen den tag zurückgezogen auf ihrem
landsitz sandringham
die winzer gab es trotzdem ein
geburtstagsständchen für sie
[Musik]
richtig groß gefeiert wird dann wie
immer erst im juni diesmal neben dem
geburtstag auch ihr 70 thronjubiläum
und wir kommen zum dfb pokal ein
arbeiter steht nach freiburg jetzt ja
auch letztlich im finale nach dem 2 1
sieg gestern abend gegen union starke
leistung der berliner die lange in
führung lagen aber noch stärker rb mit
einem last minute siegtor leipzig zum
dritten mal im pokalfinale
bevor die leipziger jubel party beginnt
trumpft union auf ein traumhaftes
zuspiel von kapitän trimmel verwirrtes
giraldo becker zum 1 0 für brillant
eingestellte berliner in der zweiten
hälfte verpasst aber nie die
vorentscheidung nur um haaresbreite
danach ein klares foul von union zirkel
im strafraum an kongo strafstoß silber
leipzig fans fiebern mit und silva
trifft zum 1 1 als alle bereits mit
verlängerung rechnen in der
nachspielzeit flankt henrys und der
eingewechselte forsberg trifft zum 2 1
für leipzig weil er bis zuletzt daran
glaubte das zeigt auch das alles geht
und wir haben es geschafft und wir
fahren nach berlin und dort heißt der
gegner dann freiburg
die pokal entscheidungen am 21 die
entscheidung in der meisterschaft die
könnte schon übermorgen fallen beim top
duell in münchen am samstagabend sollten
die bayern den titel rivalen aus
dortmund besiegen ja dann wären sie
vorzeitig meister
es ist am samstag auch das duell der
beiden top stürmer robert lewandowski
bei den bayern und in holland bei
dortmund dem polen werden ernsthafte
flops mit dem fc barcelona nachgesagt
und holland soll sich mit manchester
city so gut wie einig seien natürlich
möchtest du als trainer solche jungs so
lange wie möglich bei dir
haben um die garantie einfach auf tore
hoch zu halten der bvb wird versuchen
das toreschießen wie im hinspiel auch
auf andere schultern zu verteilen damit
nicht schon am samstag julia nagelsmann
seinen ersten titel als trainer feiern
kann
naja vielleicht macht es die doppelte
doch noch mal spannend und gewinn weiter
am wochenende ändert sich das wetter
morgen bleibt es dagegen bei vielen
wolken noch meist trocken details gleich
von katja h das heute journal sehen sie
um 21 45 mit bettina schausten tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend die ost lager hält sich
wirklich zählt auch heute kam wieder
wolkenlos osten heran und sie brachten
etwas regen mit das sehen sie an der
blauen farbe unter den wolken dieses
kühl mit nur acht grad mit sonnenschein
ging es am oberrhein bis 20 grad auf die
kommende nacht wird milder als die
vergangene auf neun grad sinken die
temperaturen am niederrhein bis auf null
grad geht es runter am alpenrand dazu
ist es in süddeutschland häufig klar
sonst aber gibt es viele wolken und hier
und da kann es auch ein bisschen regnen
klar die nacht auch in nordfriesland und
dort scheint auch morgen die sonne
wieder strahlt sonst gibt es in
norddeutschland aber viele wolken und
zum teil bleibt es auch wirklich dicht
hier zwischen der uckermark dem
spreewald im thüringer wald und dem
münsterland und da kann es hier und da
auch mal leicht tröpfeln beim wind aus
östlichen richtungen
in süddeutschland das ist freundlicher
richtung saal ein südliches rheinland
pfalz und auch vom oberrhein bis zum
bodensee da zeigt sich die sonne zum
teil strahlen sonst gibt es dichtere
wolken so ist es morgen zwischen mittel
und oberrhein auch am wärmsten mit 19
bis 20 grad sonst werden 16 bis 18 grad
erreichen im nordosten bleibt es bei 11
bis 15 grad kühler am samstag gibt es
bereits erste regenschauer am alpenrand
am sonntag breiten sich schauer und
gewitter weiter richtung mitte aus und
ähnlich wechselhaft startet die neue
woche gute nacht